- What are we gonna do today?
- Hiking, obviously.
- Oh, I'm not going hiking
with you.
- Yeah, you are.
- I'm not going hiking--
- Yes, you are.
- You know I don't like to go hiking.
- Come hiking, babe.
- No, I'm not going hiking.
You always make me go hiking.
- Hey.
(shutter clicks)
(upbeat music)
- Happy birthday.
- Thank you.
I'm so excited about tonight.
- I forgot.
- Forgot what?
- To make a reservation?
- This goes back to you
not valuing my time.
- Okay, I'll call right now.
(shutter clicks)
(upbeat music)
- Cool.
- Look at this.
Let's take a selfie.
- Yeah, let's take one.
(shutter clicks)
- Oh, I don't like my look.
- Ugh, I don't like my,
my hair.
- Wait, let me fix my hair.
Hold on.
- Okay.
(shutter clicks)
(upbeat music)
- No, I don't like, I don't like that.
- You don't like, well.
Jesus.
- Let's do it.
Wait, my eyes are burning,
here, you hold it.
(laughs)
The sunlight's that way.
(shutter clicks)
(upbeat music)
- Maybe Martin's?
- Definitely can't afford Martin's.
What about Sugarfish?
- That's out.
- Why do we go on this vacation?
Now we can't even afford to eat.
(shutter clicks)
(upbeat music)
- Your beard looks so nice.
(sighs)
- Thank you, I love that necklace, curly.
- Thank you so, so, much.
Your mom gave it to me.
- Did she?
- Yeah.
- Let's take a picture,
we look good today.
- Yeah, we look good.
Oh, look, we look so cute.
Wait take, here.
(shutter clicks)
(upbeat music)
Mwah!
(laughs)
- Eh.
Why he always do that?
(laughs)
(upbeat music)
(whooshing)
(creaking)